so a brief introduction to the Simons
Institute so we are the leading
international venue for collaborative
research in theory of computing and
related fields uh The Institute was
established in 2012 with a very generous
Grant from the Simons Foundation which
continues to support us in significant
ways and The Institute brings together
world's leading researchers in the
theory of computing and related fields
as well as the next generation of
outstanding young scholars and our main
mode of program um activities is each
semester we have two programs two
thematic programs
and that attract several long-term
visitors both senior and Junior to
Berkeley and which also include multiple
workshops that convene more short-term
visitors on a for week workshops and um
so this week is one such Workshop i'
would like to welcome you to the
workshop on problemistic circuits and
Logic the second Workshop as part of the
program on logic and algorithms in
database Theory and Ai and first I would
like to thank the organizers of this
week's workshop for their hard work in
putting together a great program and
they are um so if you're here just uh
know raise your hand or stand up Gan de
Brook who's the chair of the workshop uh
Dennis dataton
MOA and Stefan
mingle okay so okay thanks uh for the
organization so let's give them a round
of
applause and before I hand it over to
the organizers for the information about
the scientific content of the workshop
just a few logistics for the coming week
um so we have food before the talk and
during the breaks just outside the
auditorium and for lunch you're on your
own but there are many excellent choices
uh in walking distance and uh one
sincere request we make is that you
please leave any food and drinks uh
outside the
auditorium bottled water is fine but
anything else please uh leave it outside
it helps us keep the auditori clean as
you see and if you want to leave some
stuff during lunch or other times there
are lockers on the other side of the
corridor and then you can a good place
to your stuff and any a issues uh um our
videographer Omar is here to help you
and as always all the talks are recorded
and stored archived in our YouTube
channel and also live streamed so they
have a long life and impact Beyond this
week and um and so one other thing is
that if you're act for any of you who
might be active on social media like you
know Twitter X so if you consider live
tweeting from the workshop if you do
that tag us at Simon's Institute and
we'll be sure to uh
post comments and uh finally a special
thanks to the events team uh
specifically Ashley Hassen of the events
team and or who helps um and for
managing all the logistics for this
week's event and um they will also and
da and other staff will be hand who have
any questions um so with that I'll uh
hand it over to G who will say a few
words about
the everyone uh so also on behalf of uh
Stefan and Dennis and myself welcome um
so this is a workshop on on probalistic
and logical circuits um and uh I think
the reason why I was excited to uh kind
of bring this group together is because
there's really several sub communities
here that really don't know each other
and I thought maybe it would be useful
for the start of this program that I
kind of Tred to map the community for
you and then we can actually get into
the technical talks and so what we try
to do here is bring together of course
the database folks uh that have been
here also for the uh the logic program
for a while and so they've been looking
at circuits Al also for uh at least you
know 15 years in the context of
prolistic databases in numeration of
solutions to queries explanations and so
they have a very deep knowledge about
the theory of logical circuits um at the
same time we have here several people
from the machine Learning Community who
really look at circuits as uh
statistical models as generative models
or deep generative models people that
come from the some product Network
cutset community and so they think of
these as statistical models not
necessarily logical ones but in the end
there's so many commonalities that I
think it would be very useful that we
talk to each other and then maybe the
you know there's several more
communities here there's of course the
classical AI community that thinks of
prob distributions as being graphical
models and then for them uh circuits uh
and things like and or graphs are ways
of essentially thinking of how to reason
about graphical models and so that of
course connects to the the graph
Community uh and then
uh we also have many representatives
here of uh the model counting and
approximate counting and approximate
sampling communities and so they don't
they don't think of the world as being
all about circuits necessarily but they
care about the very related problem of
counting Solutions counting things and
so I hope we'll find many uh common
interests here and uh we'll hopefully
have uh talks kind of spread throughout
these communities where we can learn
from each other how people kind of
perceive these problems um and with that
I would like to invite invite then to uh
start the the first talk on circuits for
query
Providence okay thank you g um and I
need to apologize apparently I I um
mixed up the the talk title it's not the
one that is posted but it's the same
content so don't worry I just try to
make it as attractive as possible and
you should also mention this is Joint
work uh with um Paul beam nesi up Jer Le
and sudipa Roy and sudipa sits right
here uh okay so take your favorite uh
problem on Boolean formulas F this can
be sat satisfiability can be model
counting K think can be constructing a
binary decision diagram as part
particular kind of of a circuit whatever
problem you can think of so now in
general this problem is exponential in
the size of the formula but now assume
that your formula is actually the
provence or also called the linear or
the grounding of an A first order
sentence q and the only input is the
domain uh or where which to do this
where we to compute this Providence so
the question now gets more refined uh
for a fixed sentence Q the question is
what is your the complexity of your
problem whatever your problem was uh as
a function of the size of the input for
this fixed sentence Q this is the the
the problem I'm going to discuss today
uh so to make it a little bit more
refined F will be a um f will be the
provence of some fixed first or sentence
and all the results that I will mention
they will restrict the what kind of
first other sentences we are considering
and then I'm going to discuss two
problems one is complexity of the weight
weighted model counting problem for the
boan Formula F and more interestingly
I'm going to discuss the uh the size of
some of some binary decision diagrams
order binary decision diagrams free
Binary decision diagrams and decision
dnfs for this Boolean Formula F uh my
main goal is a second bullet but the
weighted model counting is a great
warmup and also establishes some some of
the
terminology a glaring Omission is the
satisfiability problem just because
nobody has apparently has looked at this
particular uh um dimension of the
satisfiability um the main message of
this talk is that we can go from logic
from syntactic analysis of The Logical
of the sentence in first logic to
algorithm and complexity um results for
the grounding of or the provence of the
boan formula resulting from that
sentence and throughout this talk I'm
going to describe some concrete results
but I'd like I my main goal is to get
you excited about the problem itself not
about the results because I think there
are many new problems that are have not
been addressed and I hope somebody will
actually address
them okay so um uh with this in mind
let's start directly with weighted model
counting uh this is a classical problem
given a Bo and formula f the model count
for f denoted sharp f is a number of
satisfying assignments of of f uh it was
proven in a classical paper by variant
in 79 actually two two comping papers
that this problem is sharply complete
even if f is restricted to a a two cnf2
a positive 2 CNF formula or a positive 2
dnf formula uh but um I'm going to
discuss a slight a slight generalization
of this problem where every boan
variable is associated with a
probability Pi for that buan variable
which is a number between zero and one
and the goal is to compute the
probability that that uh the formula is
true and for reasons I'm not going to
get into this is often called the
weighted weighted model count uh for f
and the problem is a weighted model
counting for
f so uh why do we consider the slightly
more General problem because it has a a
an important property that we need uh
namely it is um weighted model counting
can only become easier uh for sub
functions a sub function uh consist of
taking your original function f and
applying some partial substitution in
other words we set to zero or one some
variables of our choice uh and we get a
smaller formula and obviously U if we
have an algorith for computing the
probability of the original formula you
can always answer this sub function by
simply specializing those probabilities
to zero or
one we are actually going to use it in
reverse if the sub a sub function is
hard this implies that the original
formula was hard as
well okay so how do people do weighted
model counting there are essentially two
only two things you can do one is a
shanon expansion this is what all the
solvers are doing uh Shannon expansion
says pick a variable XI compute the
probability of the sub function when XI
is set to zero of the sub function when
XI is set to one and then combine them
in the right way to get the probability
of f of course you need to recurse so
this might lead to this typically leads
to an exponential time
algorithm uh the second formula is if
you're lucky and if your Boolean formula
is a conjunction of two formulas that do
not share
variables then the probability is their
product and this makes much more
progress than the shanon
expansion okay so what are the B
formulas to which for which we want to
do waight model counting they are the
provence or the lineage or the grounding
of a first order
sentence so fix a first order sentence Q
over some relational vocabulary uh the
provence of Q over a domain main size n
this is the only input a domain size n
is the following Boolean function
defined inductively on Q if Q is
universally Quantified then simply
substitute The Logical variable x with
every value in the domain takes a
conjunction if Q is a conjunction keep a
conjunction if we had an existential
quantifier or an disjunction here we
know what to do we put disjunctions uh
negation just push the negation through
the um Provence expression when we
finally reach atoms the atoms are
already grounded they have constants on
all the positions and then their um
Provence is a Boolean variable uniquely
Associated to this grounded
atum this is a Provence or the grounding
or the lineage of a first of the
sentence for a fixed domain size n a
quick example here is a universally
Quantified first order sentence and this
Provence over a domain size N is a big
big conjunction with N squared Clauses
and um yeah it's pretty easy to
read so with this definition here is a
problem that we are going to study given
a first order sentence Q uh what is the
complexity of weighted model counting of
the grounding of the Q as a function of
n as a function of the domain
size so the results all the results in
this talk will be restricted to a pretty
uh important and I should say uh severe
restriction of first of first the logic
we do not handle negations and we have a
single type of quantifier only
existential quantifiers or only
Universal
quantifiers of course nothing prevents
you from considering the problem more
General but I don't have any results to
show you there yes Mikel just to clarify
the input of the pr is the n and also
the probabilities for
varable the input is indeed n and for
the weighted model counting problem also
the the probabilities of all the
variables that's correct and so you have
a family of decision problems one for
every C right there is very very nice
observation thanks poon there is a
family of decision of actually of of
counting problems one for each different
que lots lots to study each queue a
different paper that's how we should
think about
it okay um yes assuming some
independence of when you define the
probabilities or they are the marginals
of
joint right this is an important
question so throughout the model
counting problem uh we assume that these
variables are set independently to zero
or one and the difficulty comes from the
Bo and function itself not from the
correlation there are ways to to um um
model correlations in this this setting
uh G and I we have a survey paper and
Foundations and Trends and there we
discuss how to model how to model
correlation this
setting okay good so uh these are the
definitions so let me show you the first
syntactic feature that we need to pay
attention to in the sentence in order to
understand the complexity of the the
grounded formula and that is the
hierarchy of
variables um fix a sentence Q first
sentence q and for each logical variable
let's denote at of X atoms the set of
atoms where the variable X occurs
uh we call a sentence or a query
hierarchical if for any two variables
the the set of atoms where they occur
form a hierarchy either one is contained
in the other or they are disjoined
they're not allowed to overlap and then
we call the query
hierarchical and uh it's not easy it's
not hard to prove it's actually very
easy that if you restrict your sentence
to just conjunctive queries without self
joints um very restricted class so no
self joints and conjunctive queries then
we have a quickly a dichotomy if the
query is hierarchical then the weighted
model counting is in P time otherwise it
is sharpy hard and this is immediate to
see if you look at two
examples here is a hierarchical
conjunctive query it's hierarchical
because X occurs in both atoms y occurs
only in s and they are contained in each
other and um with a little bit of
thinking you can figure out that you can
compute the probability of its lineage
of its Provence in polinomial time yes
have variables in the query how do we
Define the hierarchic property okay good
good question so this example only has
two variables uh the definition of
hierarchical also applies to multiple to
higher arties you just need to check
this for every pair of variables and the
queries become bigger I should say but
definition Still Still
applies here is an example of a non-h
hierarchical query where X occurs in RNs
y occurs in S&T they overlap none
contain the other and uh by for this
reason the query is Sharpie heart if you
read my little footnote the way to prove
Sharpie hardness is to prove that a sub
function uh is actually one of the known
classes to be sharpy hard yes what type
of reduction you you using for the
hardness proof yes just a sub
function but it's like it's it's um so
and and this case it is a it's a many
many one reduction but for the for the
big result that I'm going to show in the
next slide we have a much more
complicated reduction which is uh what's
what the um that is a car
reduction okay so we have a a little
dichotomy but it's for a very restricted
uh for a very restricted class of
queries only conjunctive queries without
self joints what happens if we allow
self joints what happens if we move on
to uh the entire class of Union of
conjunctive queries uh and the good news
is that we have a much more difficult uh
dichotomy theorem here as well for any
uh query q uh which is a unit of
conjunctive queries or a dual
universally Quantified um the we that
model counting is either in polinomial
time or it is sharply
hard uh and um I should mention that the
algorith that gives us a polinomial Time
case is elegant and simple the hardness
proof is very difficult and that is
indeed it's not a many one reduction it
is a much more difficult
proof good this was a good news so we
have this dichotomy now what is the
syntactic feature that determines this
dichotomy uh I'm not going to show this
to you in full uh but I'm going to point
out that hierarchy is not the one
hierarchy is a necessary condition for
tractability but it is not a sufficient
condition and here here is a query we
will come back to it uh which is
hierarchical it consists of two
conjunctive queries it is a union of two
conjunctive queries uh both are
hierarchical uh yet it turns out that
this query is uh sharply hard for
weighted model counting uh the Dual is a
universally Quantified um collection of
claes and it's also Sharpie
hard okay so this is all I wanted to say
about weighted model counting um the
main takeaway is that we can go from
static analysis of the query uh to
decide the complexity of the weighted
model counting problem yes that paper
with a beautiful dichotomy you did not
know the lexity of the meta problem
deciding which do you know more now
right so given two uh what is the
complexity of deciding whether we here
or here it's is still open What's the
upper bound you remember it's some
something exponential but you need to
alternate bit um from from CNF to dnf or
vice versa once for every uh quantifier
and um I don't know if this um increases
number of exponentials or not nobody has
look deeper into this
that's why I'm looking at this audience
maybe somebody will clarify the query
complexity of the decision
problem okay good so uh the main
takeaway from this part and from the
entire talk is that we can go from first
of theologic from a static analysis to
understanding the complexity and get
getting to the algorithm of the
corresponding problem um I should
mention that um antoana marili and and
San they have a beautiful p they extends
this dichotomy to much richer language
that includes data log uh it's mostly a
negative result they say that there are
no new tractable queries uh what you get
in uqs that's it um Beyond unit of
conjunctive queries it's open adding
negations or quantifier alternations uh
leaves open the
dichotomy uh I should also mention that
this result is orthogonal to a well
known dichotomy theorem for um the
counting problem of satisfiability by
Cru and Herman uh they classified the
counting problem into polinomial time or
Sharpie hard based on the type of
Clauses if the all the closes are fine
then the problem is in polinomial time
otherwise it is Sharpie hard uh this is
not what we are doing we classify the uh
our classification is based on the type
of of boan function
okay so with this in mind my next topic
is to talk about binary decision
diagrams and for this I need a quick
background into binary decision diagrams
uh a wonderful book is this one by Ingo
Vagner which I brought um I brought here
uh he explains that the research on
binary decision diagrams get gets back
to the 50s um It's a Wonderful book to
read in this talk I'm going to focus on
three types of binary decision diagrams
free Binary decision diagrams order
binary decision diagrams and decision
ddn NFS uh the first one are uh the same
as read ones branching programs subject
to the uh read ones rule this is why
they're called read ones some people
might might know them under this this
name okay so here is how they look how
the fpds look like a free Binary
decision diagram is a dag a rooted dag
where every internal note is labeled
with a boan variable and has two
outgoing edges uh one labeled zero and
the other labeled
one and the the leaves they are labeled
zero zero and or zero or one um they
represent naturally a um a boan function
which you can easily see by inspecting
the the the fbdd from the root you read
the variable X if it's zero you go left
you read y if it's one you go right uh
If U is one you go right and now you
know the function is one and this by the
way corresponds to this Min term of the
B function not x y u uh there is one
single restriction the read one's
property on any path from the root to
the leaf uh each variable can be read
only once it's an important
restriction order the binary decision
diagrams they uh further restrict fbds
to a fixed variable order on any path we
need to read the variables in the same
order uh this is not an obdd because
here we read them in the order XYZ here
we read them in the order X zy but obdds
makes them easier to to
synthesize um every Boolean function has
an exponential size obtt just a full
binary full decision tree but what we
want we want a more compact uh circuit
uh and fbds are expon can be expon
exponentially more compact than
obdds uh as a quest for even more
compact circuits uh the decision ddn NFS
they extend fbds with end nodes that
have have to be decomposable end nodes
which means that the variables on the
left descendant should be disjointed
from the variables on the right
descendant uh and turns out that they
are a little bit more compact but not by
much by only a quas polinomial am
uh we we proved that any every decision
DDF can be converted into an fbdd which
is only slightly
larger okay so there are two important
properties that we need from this D
circuit uh and they are two of the about
a dozen or so properties mentioned by
Wagner in his book The First Property is
that we can do weighted model counting
in linear time in the size of the ciruit
this is easily seen because each node in
an PDD is essentially a shanon expansion
so we can do weighted model counting in
linear linear time and the second very
easy to see it says they are close under
sub functions if I want to set y to zero
uh by simply remove this node and rewire
the the incoming edges I need to do the
same thing here uh and I get an A fbdd
which is not bigger it can even be
smaller okay so these are the um binary
decision diagrams and and um my goal is
to compile a Boolean function into a bdd
this idea of compiling knowledge was
introduced in a influential paper by
Darvish Marquee in 2002 uh and we
elevated this to what we call query
compilation uh which compiles a um the
the provence of a fixed query q as a
function of of N I should mention query
compilation turns out to be a PO chosen
term because query compilation is a very
serious problem now in database systems
uh database systems they need to compile
uh to machine code and this is a major
challenge because it can't take too much
time uh but it's completely different
problem for from our query compilation
which is a pure theoretical
study good so I still have I think 15
minutes right uh so we still have time
to go over the core of this talk
namely how to uh compile uh from ver
logic all the way to circuits and I'm
going to start with
obdds ordered binary decision diagrams
again they are fbds where we have a
fixed variable order usually denoted Pi
there's a fixed variable order that all
the paths need to Traverse uh they turn
out to be quite similar to DFAS uh and
this helps a lot in synthesizing them
synthesis is a fundamental property that
The obdds Have and the fbds do not have
uh and this the following property if we
have to obdd G1 G2 for two Boolean
functions F1 F2 and these two obdds they
use the same variable order then we can
synthesize an obdd for the conjunction
or djunction and this new obdd it's like
a product automaton it's no bigger than
the product of the two um uh
the two
graphs okay so the question to that I'm
going to ask is given a um ucq or a dual
ucq what is the size of the obdd as a
function of
n so let me give you some intuition how
we can get efficiently from queries to
obdds here is one of the queries that we
considered I took the Dual of that
hierarchical query and to give us some
intuition this is is a is grounding or
it's Provence for a domain of size
two
yes by the size you mean the optimal
size the smallest I mean the optimal
size
correct uh so uh in in this simple
example what happens if you look at the
hierarchy of the variables remember that
syntactic criteria we observe that X
occurs more in more atom than y so it
makes sense to use choose a variable
order on the groundings of s that
Traverse s in row major order and this
is what I did here so we inspect R1
first and if it's zero then we need to
expect everything in that first row and
then we ins R2 and then everything in
the second row and so on uh the obdd has
size
n and synthesis allows us to construct
more complicated obdds for more
complicated sentences here is the second
sentence it's almost identical to the
first one uh but we have t instead of R
importantly uh the hierarchy of the
variables is the same uh this also wants
to Traverse s in row major order uh and
we get a similar
obdd with the same variable order for S
both Traverse as in row major order so
now we can compute an obdd for the
conjunction a much more complicated
query the conjunction of C two uh and it
turns out this size it's not even
quadratic if you work it out a little
bit it's only linear in
N so these obds can be very very
efficient of course this basic
construction uh doesn't work all the
time here is when it
fails uh first of all it fails if the
query is non hierarchical this is a dual
of the RSD query we we saw earlier here
s would like to be traversed in R major
order in order to match R uh but it
would like to be traversed in colum
major order to match t
and it doesn't it's not obvious that we
have a good
traversal but it it gets more subtle
than this before I show you the next
queries um I want to drop quantifiers
because they they clutter the the the
slides so look at those quantifiers they
are gone okay so no more quantifiers so
here is my second query uh where the
quantifiers are dropped but they should
be there uh this is a hierarchical query
um the first Clause is hierarchical so
is a second but the first Clause wants
to Traverse S one in row major
order the second Clause wants to
Traverse S1 and column major order there
is a conflict and it's not clear if we
ever have a good Traverse order
traverser it gets even more weird uh you
can stretch it even further um S1 wants
to be traversed in row major order but
S1 and S2 must be traversed in the same
order because of the second clause and
to insist on being traversed in a kind
of major order you see the
conflict uh continuing like this uh for
every K you can construct a query that
has K plus one Clauses that has this
this conflict between the rightmost the
left most close and the rightmost close
yes Remy so in we we should have
exential so here you always have for all
so what is for all
is right so um um I should have
emphasize this so the question is what
about the existential that now became
universals uh for every query the um
weighted model counting problem or the
circuit computation problem is the same
as for its
dual the Dual is obtained by replacing
exist with for all replacing and with or
and replacing or with with and and if
you have negation then you keep negation
as well this is a dual so uh this
universally Quantified query if you take
a dual Universal quantifiers they become
existentials or becomes end and this is
indeed our rstd
query similarly you can play the same
game with each of these HK queries and
get a union of conjunctive queries by
taking the Dual I find it more
convenient actually to use a universally
Quantified expression this is why I
chose them
so the the the takeaway here is that all
these queries they they don't seem to
have a good variable order and indeed
what we proved is that the lineage
expressions for each of these
HK um um has obdds which are provably
exponentially large in n in the domain
size notice this this a result that
applies to
fbds Beyond
obdds so it's a it's a stronger it's a
stronger result
uh it's it's kind of expected and by the
way decision dnfs they are not much
better because they're only qu polom
more efficient than
fbds okay so with this uh result in mind
we can examine the second syntactic
feature that helps us understand the
complexity of um um query eval of query
compilation which are inversions and
inversions are just the the elevating
the the phenomenon you saw in the
previous slide to a general query an
inversion is a sequence of atoms that um
essentially says you don't you don't
have a good variable order in the first
atom this
the you have two variables X and Y X
occurs in strictly more atom than y in
the last atom y occurs in strictly more
atoms than x and in between they insist
that they will be in the same order and
that gives us a conflict so here is an
example um uh these um the these four
atoms here they form an inversion of of
length this is a two inversion in
H2 okay so this is a second syntactic fe
uh feature that we're going to to
examine and uh it turns out that this is
necessary and sufficient to uh decide
whether your um Provence has polinomial
size
obdds if Q has no inversions then its
Provence has an obdd which is
essentially linear uh it's linear in the
number of ground
atoms uh and if the query has an
inversion then it's obdd is
exponentially
large uh at this point
yes second lower B is uncondition or is
lower B the second one is unconditioned
uh I I think one thing to to worry about
is I stated the the lower Bound for the
for the HK queries as lower bonds for
fbds but here I only stated for
obdds and this is not an accident the
way we prove this lower bound is through
a reduction that in involve involves um
synthesis here is how the proof goes
imagine that you have an obdd for the
provence of Q then what we can do we can
create k + one subf functions one for
each Clause of HK by specializing all
the other all the unwanted boan
functions so from from one obdd we now
we have K plus one obdds one for each uh
Clause of HK and uh we are we are in
good shape because all these obdds they
use the same variable order so now we
can synthesize them to get an obdd for
HK uh which we know has to be big and
this what this is what gives us the
exponential lower Bound for the size of
an
obdd yes before in the previous slide
you saw us this hierarchal queries for
which synthesis is not possible but
these queries were easy for model
counting by by what you told us before
so what so what is the point just that
synthesis fails even for easy counting
is that yeah foress one one slide ahead
of me this is exactly question I'm after
uh so some queries they they turn out to
be easy for weighted model counting uh
however there are no polinomial size
obdds for these queries but I should
mention that the the H Quake queries all
these queries are sharply
hard however the statement for kud to
still holds and I want to get there and
I still have six minutes to get
there okay so uh uh we have a very
simple dichotomy for obdds if the query
has an inversion forget it the obdds are
exponentially large if the query doesn't
have an an inversion it's fantastic the
obdd is essentially linear in the size
of your of the number of ground atoms
which is end to the arity of the largest
arity of your um of your
schema okay um good so this is for's
question
uh is it sufficient are all queries that
have a polinomial time obdd are these
all the queries for which we can compute
weighted model counting in polinomial
time and the answer is no because for
weighted model counting we use a a a
technique uh which we don't know how to
transfer to ciruits and that is
inclusion
exclusion here is a query for which
inclusion exclusion uh Works beautifully
there is it looks like H1 we have this
Inversion from the first Clause to the
second qu Clause but there is a third
Clause here and remember everything here
is universally
Quantified uh and because of that um the
the only way this last Clause can be
true is if RX is true for every X or t
of Y is true for every y so we can
separate these two Universal quantifiers
then we can distribute uh we can
simplify a little bit these two um
um um these two CNF expressions and we
get our first order sentence as a
disjunction of two
conjunctions why is this good because
now the
probability uh we can express it as an
inclusion exclusion formula probability
of the first um um uh conjunct plus the
probability of the second minus the
probability of the both to both together
and the last expression simplifies again
and we end up with three Expressions all
of them are inversion free and therefore
we can compute their probabilities in
polinomial
time the takeaway is that we can compute
the probability of QV in polinomial time
however it's obdd is provably
exponentially
large yes go but what about D do we know
something about U we know something
about DF I'm not going to talk about it
that's going to be the next talk okay so
um uh again the my message is from
static analysis of Q uh we can get to a
um to judgments about the optimal size
of the obdd for uh it its Provence uh
but the second message is what Fon
observed obdds are essentially
incomplete they do not capture
everything we know how to compute and po
noral
time um I should also mention that um
Paul beam and Vincent Le uh they showed
that a similar theorem also holds for
sdds a a strictly more powerful class of
circuits than
obdds uh so the interesting question is
uh how do we make this class of circuits
complete are the fbds
complete so uh this is going to be the
last topic of my talk and I think I can
finish it in two two minutes uh so fbdd
and decision ddn and
Fs um so by completeness I mean that if
we can compute uh if you can comp do
weighted model counting in polinomial
time it is the case that the lineage has
an efficient U an efficient circuit in
this case we're looking for an efficient
fbdd this is a question to address and
and the answer is no both of them are
incomplete and I'm going to show you why
uh in order to to give you the example
for which they are incomplete I need to
start from H3 which had four Clauses
they're all universally Quantified for
me so yeah not not existential they're
universally Quantified because I chosen
to be uh conjunctions of this Junction
that oppos vice versa uh and I'm going
to take these
Clauses four Clauses and arrange them in
a different way uh it's going to be a um
very small um dnf formula that you can
see here it's not super important that
we look at the details what we proved is
that a probability of this new query
called qw uh can be computed in
polinomial time however every fbdd or
decision ddn andf is exponentially
large how do we compute this probability
in polinomial time well we know what to
do we apply apply the inclusion
exclusion
formula but there is a problem here by
the time we reach the the conjunction of
all these terms we get a conjunction of
all these four Clauses some of them are
repeated here uh but this is exactly H3
for which we cannot compute the
probability but it turns out that
because of the shape of this of this
formula um these two terms which are
both hard they cancel out and since they
cancel out we are left with only terms
that no longer have an inversion uh at
least one Clause is missing from each of
these terms and uh it turns out that uh
this query we can do weight and model
counting in polinomial time I have here
one line about the proof which is uh
very subtle and kind of long it it had a
cool idea there but I'm going to skip it
because I am running out of time good so
quick quick take away from this part uh
both fpds and decision dnfs are in
complete uh I should mention that uh the
the theorem I mentioned has a slight
generalization from qw to a slightly
larger class of formulas uh but um we
still don't know exactly which uh
sentences admit a polinomial time fbdd
or decision ddn andf the other thing to
take away is how powerful inclusion
exclusion is with cancellation uh this
this turns out to give us a lot of power
for computing the weighted model for
doing weighted model
counting good so uh quick summary uh the
the main takeaway I'd like you to get
from this talk is how to get from logic
to algorithm through static analysis of
the first order sentence we can reach we
can draw conclusions about the
complexity of a boan formula obtained by
instantiating Q over a domain of size
and uh and the syntactic features that
we discussed are the hierarchy the
inversions and a much more complicated
one to see which are those cancellations
and they're related to a mous function
that um that Mikel will I hopefully talk
about lots of open problems and I hope
to get some of you excited about about
them what about going Beyond uqs and
their duals like adding quantifiers or
negations don't try to add recursion
that's done Antoine has has done this
and it doesn't work we don't I mean if
you solved it and the answer is no you
don't get any
um tractable queries what about the
dichotomy for the full first of the
logic interesting if we have such a
dichotomy we will not be able to decide
between the hard and the easy queries by
tra Andro result that would be a very
interesting dichotomy completely
different from the one we
have what about
satisfiability nobody has looked at this
you have an arbitrary um an arbitrary um
first of the sentence you look at the
groundings uh what about the
satisfiability of all the sub function
that you can get from that grounding I
think it's a very interesting problem to
study I have no idea how to approach it
uh and the big question for for this
morning is is there a complete family of
circuits for unions of conjunctive
queries and nikel will look into this
and on this note I will stop here say
thank you and sorry for running over
three
minutes
have time for a
question can I can I ask questions
directly is there a
microphone
BOS
I just wanted to to check I correctly
understand this question about sat
because I think it's it's it's
interesting
[Music]
so Daniel open question about sat is it
uh you fix a formula say in logic and
you want to know if given a database
there is a sub database that satisfies
the formula um I would say given a
domain size n yeah you ground it you get
a single grounding and now I examine all
the sub formulas which is essentially
choing your
database so then these for these sub
formulas they're not given as input I'm
not sure uh well you want all of them to
be decided by time to prove that the
entire class
you can formulate your
you
okayy hard
yeah maybe just a super quick question
most of your results are with
respect your results are with respect to
to the size what is the the Astic
complexity or it depends on so for very
large n what happens
very large
Andor number of R and functions is two
to the end and you you you see how many
how many OB F can construct a b size it
it turns out that on average you need
exponential size ciruit to represent all
the functions only a small fraction will
have a pol size C but it doesn't go
Beyond exponential exponential is thank
you yes uh so you said
that is it always I don't think it
works it always the case that when the
size is
polom then generating it synthesizing it
is a
pol so this is a very nice observation
thanksa so uh it could be the case in
principle that the size of BD is small
but is difficult to
synthesize however we did not encoun
this in all example that we know
whenever the size is small we also know
how to
syze you can even think of aniz problem
in hand just have a 01 circuit very
simple but you can't synthesize it
right thanks again